hey youtubers happy holidays so we just
learned a whole bunch of stuff about
Avengers infinity where they just did
like a big info dump about all these
characters are including so there's
going to be a breakdown as well as some
info on the changes they're making the
people's backstories there is a new
brand of the spider-man giveaway going
on now - all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
during the break so we all learned that
Avengers infinity war is going to be
shooting principal photography with all
the actors starting in January so [ __ ]
is getting real and they finally
revealed a cast list of the characters
that are going to appear now they're
always like a few minor characters they
just don't include on there there's
going to be like 60 plus big-name
characters total a lot of those will be
in background shots in addition to the
main actors that are going to be the
ones that you see most of the time on
screen so the big surprises or maybe not
big surprises or that they confirm the
Guardians Captain Marvel and they did
not put spider-man on the list so
everyone's freaking out wait a minute
does this mean that spider-man is not
going to be an infinity war no that's
just because it's a separate deal with
Sony they just have to make terms for
the financial arrangement of how it's
going to work on the back end the
lawyers from Marvel and Sony have to do
Thunderdome two men enter one spider-man
leave so spider-man will be a part of
infinity war is just that they need to
haggle over all the minor details so
don't worry about that the Russos have
already said that he's coming back an
infinity war he'll have some suit
upgrades they will do all of the
spider-man things don't worry we'll talk
about that in a second the other big
surprise is that they're changing
captain Marvel's origin story they've
already kind of explained that like both
Kevin Feige in the person that's writing
the script for the solo Captain Marvel
movie have just said that her origin
story the classic one just reads too
much like Green Lantern in there just so
many reasons why they do not want you to
associate Captain Marvel with Green
Lantern you know let alone you know that
movie bombed too they want you to be
thinking about Marvel stuff not DC stuff
when you go see a Marvel movie so they
just debuted a new Captain Marvel comic
where they teased the change in her
origin story they were very nebulous
about it like very ambiguous just this
like white light enveloping her talking
about inheriting all these wondrous
powers from a different people's
planet she's talking about the Cree so
she doesn't exactly reference the
artifact that gave her powers like the
original thing that gave her her powers
was an exploding psyche magnetron which
was a Cree weapon now it sounds like
it's going to be something that's a
little bit different and there is no
reference of Captain Marvel the original
Captain Marvel so you can kind of see
what they're doing they're like slowly
moving away from green lantern type
stuff but try not to change her origin
that much so in the movies I feel like
we're all on the same page when we're
like yet they're probably going to give
her an infinity gem that's where her
powers will come from so that she's just
as powerful is Scarlet Witch because
right now vision and Scarlet Witch are
the most Opie characters on the Avengers
we don't know the full extent of scarlet
witch's powers like they continually
evolve so they were kind of like the
Hulk's powers like he just gets stronger
and stronger the madder he gets so
Scarlet Witch just gets more and more
powerful the more she learns to use her
abilities so back around Comic Con when
Kevin Feige announced brie Larson as
Captain Marvel he was saying she's going
to be the most opie Avengers hero
character they've ever introduced into a
movie so he wasn't necessarily saying
that she's more powerful than Thanos
because if they're changing a bunch of
the comic book characters for the movies
they're also going to change stano's
just a little bit but I think that he's
just going to be Opie enough that he can
hand the Avengers their asses and make
the Hulk hurt so don't expect them to
say exactly how powerful everyone is
like they're not going to put a number
on it or anything like that even
Elizabeth Olsen explained that when she
was working with the Russos and Joss
Whedon to create her Scarlet Witch
character they were very ambiguous about
what her powers were like one of the big
things that Joss Whedon did with her
when they were first working on the
character was figure out the hand
movements that she did like she almost
looks like she's weaving spells but
that's not really how her powers in the
movies work she doesn't have her Chaos
magic like she does in the comics but
the big difference when she got to
Captain America Civil War is that you
know she's supposed to be way more
powerful but the thing is is she said
the Russos had absolutely no idea what
to do with her powers they were like we
don't really understand the full extent
of your powers which just sounds
mind-blowing that the directors wouldn't
know exactly how her care
- works so it just sounds like they're
building themselves room to change their
minds down the road like when they're
making infinity war if they want Scarlet
Witch to be able to do something that's
just completely outlandish and
overpowered then she'll be able to do
that so I understand if you're a little
frustrated with them not like completely
nailing down what these characters can
do it's just the way that movies get
made it's like Batman fighting Superman
there's there's always like these leaps
and logic you have to make like why
would Batman be able to get the upper
hand on Superman if Superman is super
fast is he just not that smart is he
just not paying attention like you
always had to find ways to explain the
logic but what about Thanos what about
his powers I think the really fun thing
that nobody's really been talking about
that much is what are they going to
change about Thanos like what are we
going to see him do because the whole
point of infinity war is that Thanos is
one person he does have an army behind
him but he will be able to defeat the
Avengers by himself
but how is he going to do that like what
is he gonna do to defeat the Hulk
someone who is arguably unkillable like
Thanos has very powerful energy blast
physically he's very strong - so he
could beat the crap out of the Hulk but
the Hulk would recover very quickly and
just bounce right back even stronger as
he gets madder
so just expect vanos to be very
resistant to physical damage and mental
damage like the big thing in age of
Ultron is that Scarlett which puts the
whammy on the Avengers and kind of turns
them against each other she's able to
control the Hulk's mind so I wouldn't be
surprised if she's not able to do that
the Thanos next on the list
spider-man what's going on with
spider-man powers in infinity war well
he's not going to change that much he'll
probably get a cooler suit they'll have
some extra abilities a little more stark
tech a little more hardcore for fighting
people like Danno so I wouldn't be
surprised if he gets like a little bit
closer to comic book iron spider but the
whole thing about Spider Man in Civil
War was that he was like this little kid
experiencing this giant conflict like oh
my god this is so crazy and I have
school on Monday that's going to be the
same deal in infinity war he'll still be
in high school he'll still be a kid Tony
Stark will still treat him like a kid so
like they'll go pick spider-man up go
fight Thanos and then Tony will go drop
him off
cool the next day so spider-man really
brings the little kids perspective to
this big galactic universe changing
story that's the whole reason for him
being there and and obviously he's
probably going to out quit Thanos that's
probably going to be one of the funniest
things to come out of the movie watching
spider-man try to out quit Thanos and we
haven't heard a whole lot of fan oohs
puns but just imagine Darth Vader puns
in rogue one only coming out of Thanos
mouth be careful not to choke on your
own ambitions Peter Parker and speaking
of quips what about the Guardians too so
we pretty much have the main guardians
roster with the addition of nebula so
nebula is supposed to be in infinity or
which i think is great because Karen
Gillan's awesome and I can't wait to see
what they do with her character in
Guardians 2 we won't even have to wait
that long to find out because guardians
is coming out in the spring so the thing
about guardians is the James Gunn has
been so funny when he's talked about how
his films fit into the main Marvel
continuity he's probably joking when he
says this but he said things like well
you know I don't have to worry about the
main continuity because I'm in a
different universe like the guardians
are not in the same universe as the
other Marvel characters so he said that
in a really offhanded way I do not think
that the guardians are in a different
universe I think they're just in a
different part of the universe that's so
far away that they don't necessarily
need to reference everything that's
going on on earth the connective tissue
for bringing them closer to earth space
is the Thor movies because Thor is the
earth-based Avenger but it's also kind
of a space based movie because Asgard is
in a different place in outer space so
the last big puzzle piece is obviously
Doctor Strange most of you probably knew
that he was going to show up in infinity
war they're gonna have all kinds of fun
pairing him off with the other Avengers
characters the Thor teaser at the end of
Doctor Strange was just a taste for that
so just imagine how his personality will
work with someone like Robert Downey jr.
on screen it'll be crazy but a lot of
you have asked about where the infinity
gems are where's the soul gem it's the
only one that's missing now we'll
probably get a taste for that in the
Thor movie it'll either be inside
someone else like Heimdall or it'll be
inside somewhere else like Sekar because
they've teased the Planet Hulk storyline
the planets
our has the old power so there's just a
number of different comic-book concepts
that they can use and co-opt for soul
gem purposes but do not forget that
vision still has the mind gem in his
forehead somehow Thanos is going to have
to rip that out to put it in the
Infinity Gauntlet and then you have him
collecting all the other gems
so really thor ragnarok is probably
going to be the first taste we get for
him assembling gems in the gauntlet like
do not be surprised if he puts at least
one gem in the gauntlet at the end of
that movie but I know we haven't talked
a lot about black panther so there's
just so much about that movie that we
haven't learned yet so what's going to
happen is is that they'll be in
production next year so we'll probably
learn all kinds of stuff about black
panther as they're rolling out guardians
spider-man in Thor Ragnarok that's right
they're going to be so many Marvel
movies next year it is going to be
amazing and that says nothing about the
new Star Wars Episode 8 film or the DC
films like Wonder Woman and Justice
League really like 2017 is seeming so
much better than 2016 right now I cannot
wait to see everything but let me know
in the comments which new character are
you most excited about in infinity war
seeing spider-man with all the Avengers
on-screen again meeting Captain Marvel
for the first time or just seeing fan
o's hand every single avenger their
asses as he assembles the gauntlet just
like he did in the comics I will say
congratulations to this week's fighter
man giveaway winner Candice Simmons you
win an Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there is a new round that starts
now in this video I'll just announce a
winner the next time I post a Marvel
video I will be doing some Christmas
themed comic book videos this week like
spider-man saves Christmas be sure to
leave Santa some extra ammo underneath
the tree with all the milk and cookies
so is there any like special Christmas
style comic book videos that you guys
want me to do or special stories just
let me know in the comments there's
going to be all kinds of stuff happening
this weekend so happy holidays everybody
new Marvel and DC coming real soon will
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my breakdown with the
Darth Vader WTF scenes in rogue one and
you can click here to learn all about
the Justice League teaser they just
dropped thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you